how to capture the attention of a
disparate group of journalists from
across Europe each with their own
priorities deadlines and attention spans
one way is to invite a star in the
constellation of EU Affairs to field
questions freely and openly another way
is to offer something different really
different this is the first time when
where there is a real European campaign
this is the first time where you can
feel the media being really interested
about the elections including of course
you are also deciding about the
executive about the government daily
life government of European Union which
is the European Commission turnout in
2009 averaged 43% but Parliament has
more paranoid important legislation has
been passed lately on among other issues
farming fisheries and banking union and
you expect to turn out to to rise or
decline this time I'm really convinced
that they turn out this time will be
higher than it was in 2009 and that we
will reverse the trend the view among
journalists themselves attending the
seminar was somewhat mixed you see a lot
more activities and then in the past and
I think that this promise that you know
the winner will basically be the
Commission president to put it simply be
something that Kevin eyes the people I
feel that the European Parliament tried
to gain a lot more power but I think in
general in the view of the citizens
citizens of Czech Republic there are
maybe no no difference reach is the key
across the EU citizens frequently say
that despite the increasing
incorporation of EU law in national law
Brussels remains distant and irrelevant
it's extremely difficult to convey what
goes on in the European Parliament what
happens in Brussels with European
Commission and the European Council back
to people at home and to explain how
these big changes impact on their lives
with what they do we'll find out soon
enough whether Parliament's outreach
campaign abiding economic woes or the
rise of the extreme right indeed all
three has mobilized votos or whether
it's paralyzed